these on HBO's ballers once again which
returns to HBO once again this very
Sunday at 10:00 Eastern Time Rob Corddry
could add to user you as always good to
see you who's on this season we just saw
a clip of Emeril songs you guys only got
t says oh of course I'm dead you said
he's he's awesome listen you know all
the football players are surprisingly
good actors I don't know if I've said
this on your show before but like go for
it it says my theory at least is because
they're they risk their lives of their
day jobs every day it's like they come
onto a set and it's easy yeah you know
there's no one's out to kill them and if
some we're just giving them waters and
coffees and if something doesn't go
right they get to do it again yeah they
get to do it and the best version of it
gets used it's like they're always
scoring touchdowns it's what it is it's
could you imagine if they got actually
to do that in football like you know
yeah right to do overs re let's just do
it again and we're gonna do it till we
get it right actors were the ones that
got concussions all the time like oh god
get your brain rattled upset and you
know the guy the one director who would
say let's do it again even though they
know they got the shot would have to be
Belichick right wouldn't that be like oh
now I know just to get in our heads
that's what I doing that could be a
great director you think so being good
anything you know I'm a Pats fan so I
think he'd be a good he'd be a good to
anything yeah waiter he'd be a great you
name something math teacher well look
over at Chris Brockman right they're a
great cover man have you seen have you
seen the Nantucket magazine no no cover
it Oh Brockman pick it up bring it over
to rob corddry we're gonna do this right
here I'm right freaking now this is the
summer of edition of Nantucket magazine
I love a hook over yeah Jim Lee lady I'm
not turning it on where there is turning
it on man yeah the sexy so he's a model
as well yeah there's a hole would you
like gonna giant maritime did you like
that College I this yeah what I like
what the whole column you would you like
to take it home and a great coffee table
but the Audrey - if I really have the a
stagette substantial like
a man himself reads this who reads the
people in Nantucket action you know what
I spoke too soon
this looks like a good magazine it's all
this this is the whole magazine it's
like yeah expensive houses houses you
can't afford yeah and a photo shoot of
the great coach to never like football
that is Bay and all the houses he could
afford whoo so ok so I interrupted in a
way Terrell Suggs is really good who
else is a Hobbesian every time in the
time I spend with like you know that we
got our villain this year is Steve
Guttenberg nice and oh my god that first
of all I've worked with very few people
like Steve Guttenberg Henry Winkler's
and is one of the henry winkler's one of
them just the kind of guy that it's like
so big-hearted and awesome but you just
want to be that person sure I model my
life after them Steve Guttenberg one day
we're shooting and he goes up to a bunch
of flowers and he's just just in awe of
these beautiful come hours like they're
creatures living creatures any touching
them going how do you grow such
beautiful things in California like he's
never seen a flower touching them like
cooking life from them and passing
lights to them
that's Guttenberg I'm not kidding if did
you pick his brain about any of his work
when you're in downtown would Steve
guten
and if so which one would what would it
be uh well of course not it would be
police academy movies would it yeah and
you know what he was the guy like I was
a big Chevy Chase fan growing up and and
I was after this police academy movies
Steve Guttenberg was like kind of the
next Chevy Chase right handsome kind of
a wiseass that was his thing but he's
not like that at all like he's I don't
think he had it in him to beat like
Chevy Chase is though why he has a black
heart he's a wise ass Steve Guttenberg
is too he wanted to do theater and like
really I don't know touch the flowers
well I mean if I rob corddry fatted
choice I would go diner seriously with
him just to ask him what it was like to
be in the movie diner and those yo-yo of
course yang yang's and diner with with
the forget because everybody was in
diner
Mickey Rourke yeah diner heaven bacon
they were all oh my God we're all in
half and also just maybe cocoon just
like give me a great [ __ ] give me a
great story but how is Hume Cronyn
really live or get older and will never
die exactly give me your best Wilford
Brimley there is it good Burke you know
did I give me your best he actually did
he was like he's like a good no it was a
really story so much as I think he said
he's a bit of a cantankerous fellow like
something like that
you know Wilford Brimley like you'd
imagine generous obably kind of a jerk
could you just seem like the guy yeah
made even in commercials when what was
he selling and those oh he was selling
about some about diabetes you're like
you don't want to get this disease you
jerk like you're just selling it with
negativity like god we buy it already
I'm dying
[Laughter]
so Gutenberg is the bad guy in the same
way there Andy Garcia exactly right yeah
a different kind of bad guy so it's like
Gutenberg is so he brings like this
sleazy charm to it and awesome and Steph
Curry oh yeah yeah did you meet him got
to meet Steph Curry in the world pretty
pretty awesome I mean you could say
probably at least the most popular
athlete alive right now right Steph
Curry I'd say well I mean one of them
yeah you put them up there with LeBron
yeah you definitely would I mean right
now right and was like well you can also
tell when the people are on the set how
people react to somebody yeah coming on
well I mean even the rock is kind of
starstruck by Steph Curry you know and
they're like could put by the way you
could put Dwayne Johnson as the most
famous person right now on Planet oh
yeah absolutely
which is mind-boggling to me you know
that that I'm doing the show with that
number one actor in the world could
clearly say that you do say it it's it's
like journalists have said it and
written about it right it's nudes it's
like and and it's it's still
mind-boggling to me and I sometimes
watch him watch wane.com blink because
we're really good friends and he's just
like I'm such a normal dude in and I
it's
it's it's hard to wrap your head around
hmm you know how just big physically and
metaphorically mandatories the same way
too yeah he really hasn't seen those two
together they're both huge of course and
I'm just like this little that little
cartoon dog bouncing around on me I got
hey smarty what are we what about this
guy and curry is just you know I mean he
talked about being a dad too I mean
well he's also like um he's a charming
dude Steph Curry just just like the rot
like to see that kind of charm charm
meeting charm right you think it would
be like to charm magnets bouncing off
each other yeah but it was it was
amazing so they didn't to charm Mac they
do not repel him no they just on total
a-hole okay well yeah the right side on
the right or positive and negative side
I want to take a 60-second break come
back talk a little bit of patriots with
you talk a little bit of football all
right fantasy we always used to have a
good chat about that I would love to
hear a little bit for me a little bit
more ballers with Rob Corddry when we
come back in 60 seconds yeah
welcome back to this edition of the Rich
Eisen show HBO's ballers returns on
Sunday at 10:00 Eastern Time Rob Corddry
back here on a show and it's too bad you
have the worst ledin for ratings
purposes on HBO yes we are actually I
brought the Game of Thrones appetizer
mm-hmm they're like our medium heat
chicken wings hmm - the main ballers
course of steak like a medium-rare steak
there your pig in a blanket
exactly they're fresh beginning as we
call them to name it if you had a
restaurant your culture yeah -
beginnings are in Boston you just call
them status we're gonna we're going to
get a couple status before balling
what's your favorite star over there man
probably like a mixed plate of status
right like yeah i'm swaggin egg rolls so
assessments and egg rolls I like
calamari yeah hustle some boneless
buffalo wings a pretty good guy good I
need some bones in my wings dude yeah
man 100% maybe some of them potato skin
oh yeah skins fish all most low - ah
loaded Lauren's can low to get no sour
cream I know that for girls yeah that's
for gamma bacon I want cheddar cheese
feta cheese is that the worst most
botched accent in India in television
movie it's hard to do it's hard to do
are you from originally myth which is
like 10 minutes south of Boston you know
you could see the skyline did you never
have that accent I did I had it very
strong but I did theater in college and
my only notes I would get in college
where like the cut the character
opposite my characters was named Arnold
the only notes I'd get were okay Rob
it's Arnold say Arnold on on Arnold
Terry can rap my mouth around it it took
me so it took me about six months to
just finally lose it and then I had to
do it for something and it took me a
while to get it back because really I
believe that the Boston accent is just
kind of an affectation anyway what I
mean I I would when I was a kid I had I
had to I didn't have one but
the third grade I was made fun of by my
friend's father because I went I said
out yeah can Marx come out and play and
he was like mom whose mark it names Mac
I was shamed into a Boston accent by by
Fred's dad and up and so that I put it
on and then eventually became my accent
you know and I think people could you
notice like people when they get quieter
in Boston else that they'll they'll add
their hours but it's kind of a you know
hard work for them
and but then when there are their bodies
as Isaac you know you can't understand
where there's a yeah and now you're
you're you're with ballers which is
produced by the ultimate Mac yeah I know
in history of man just do the conversion
Wahlberg I did a commercial at him and
he I love the business Mark Wahlberg
because he goes on Bobby because you
know I'm from Boston he's from Boston
you got I'm immediately Bobby for some
reason every name if you can be you'd be
Richie if it has a you can add a
diminutive they will be added I II or
why yeah and so he's like a Bobby we got
to get Twain to do seven seven or eight
seasons of all's and I was like that's
your job man and he goes I know I know
we're trying to incentivize them are you
I don't like this business side of Mark
Wahlberg the the whole say hi to your
mother for me that they used to do in
Senate but Andy Sandberg did that right
on Saturday Night Live multiple yeah
that that was the bit that he played for
Mark Wahlberg's as you know where he was
a mighty hi to your mother for me was it
at the Masters which golf tournament was
it rather he's yelling and where he was
instead of somebody screaming you demand
anyway so himself there would never
happen to the Masters yeah somebody
screamed said if you de man or you know
he just screamed out say hi to your
mother for me on a tee box as killed by
the whole guy became Jay hi to your
mother from if that could be the new
Baba Booey maybe maybe we could try and
affect them what do you think of Rob
Corddry of ballers right here on the
Rich Eisen show what do you think of the
Patriots this year of because that guy
over there he's Chrissy yes the
Boston phrase yep keep saying 19 and Oh
which you in Edelman called talk about
he called this past week quote unquote
stupid what's he supposed to say Edelman
is not going to say yeah right we're
going 90 no no guys what what is he
supposed to say though what's what was
his like he's like listen we're just
going to get out there with play one
game is going to Belichick you do the
belch attack thinking about depending on
your one-on-one game it makes me furious
we're just out there we're on the field
we're tossing the ball around we're
catching it if you'd like to pull up
that man Tucket magazine if it just
thumb through it see if there's any 90
no conversation in an era a Tennessee
information in here whatsoever well
unless you want to buy one of those
houses now that I fancy I guess like the
top 10 pick is a nice colonial and
that's one way to describe 19 at what so
what do you think I mean this is the
granting 19 and oh that's heaven yeah so
does Edelman so does Brady of course
they do
I mean worse it's gonna be the next oh
who knows how long can Brady play 25
more years hit 30 more years can't put
anything past I know right
I mean it's going to be a lot as long as
that I think they're just gonna yeah of
course they're gonna that's all I know
I I told you like on the break I bet I
was in a lot of airports this last week
and I was the fantasy magazines are out
they are because you know it's like the
websites are still doing sort of you
know there's still got baseball going on
and and but the magazines are so
old-school you know I don't know what to
do with them anymore I'm like
highlighting things and I'm like I gotta
wait for like well I mean because you're
not you're a periodical guy you're an
old-school like you wanted because you
can get this stuff you know I you're
like having paper in my hand but I'm
still I'm started starting to like even
I'm getting confused by it I've gotta
like once because you're an absurd
number of leagues right or because it's
not fabulous I'm still in like six
leagues I got on right I got to cut back
I just don't know what to cut one of
them's are like a Adult Swim League that
I've won two years I'm the only two-time
winner a big deal that's not to bring
walk me through else you got um and then
we've got then we've got I'm in a family
League which is just kind of a fun
oh then Nate's got a league my brother
Nate when that's his like and that's my
real competitive one that's a hardly now
that's the one that you okay keep you
out and I've got this one sort of we
call ourselves the Hollywood phonies and
that's like Paul Scheer and a bunch of
UCB guys Matt Walsh Matt Besser you know
okay Rob riggles in it he's terrible is
he really terrible he's terrible at
fantasy it's just it just yeah he's just
kidding kids to kids and city that just
aw come on like he plays them on there
by weeks and stuff these Apple I'm Scott
we got a Jerry O'Connell is pretty good
okay
and the fourth league that's the for the
two others exactly I only said four yeah
maybe I'm only in know there's another
one I don't even know I don't even know
which one is the one you want to win
more than any other because my brother's
like Nate's League and it's hard I lose
in that just like regular but you got
yeah yeah a bunch of dudes with nothing
better to do once your friends yeah who
just yeah that's what these like they
study they study and they're they're
like trash talk is mean personal because
we all know each other and we're like
yeah well you're just a bad person it's
that kind of stuff yes so it's really
that's really hardcore and Dondre so
happen maybe it's for that man how the
hell do you enough time to find how many
kids you have
I've got you kids okay who don't I go
away for it's going to like we're going
on vacation or family vacation I get
back like August 4th and then I'm going
to be gone to Fantasyland in Fantasyland
until September 7 and then Sundays
they'll come down every once in a while
and sit with me and talk about how much
they hate football and they do like it
they're just trying to be like you know
contradictory that their children that's
and then they'll be like Daddy what team
do you want I'm like well the red white
and blue one of course because I'm an
American I like the other one just to
see jerk are there any pink ones daddy
no ballers on HBO coming back on Sunday
with Rob Corddry
so last one for you because we talked
about how Dwayne John
since most popular guy on earth right
now do you think you are doing a show at
the 46th president of the United now
let's get something straight right now
all right
who cares first for one thing this is
gone just goes to show is Trump has
proven one thing it's that our mothers
were right what our mothers have told us
our whole lives is finally true that
anybody can become president so I would
not put a pat he'd be a better president
probably but I'm just sick of getting
asked that question so I'm going to
announce right now in the Rich Eisen
show I'm making this announcement yes I
am going to be running for president
the anti-rock candidate I'm just going
to be telling secrets about him hmm
so he'll just keep his mind on the
ballers game that's the platform that's
my platform there he's got a job to do
and yeah yeah was that Mark Wahlberg
incentive to use I guess yeah yes I mean
they're incentivizing with your campaign
that's right mark and here they lower
like he gets his voice goes oh no
because he's got a little I don't do it
very good I just very very soft-spoken
that's the toughest accent to do it
hotter great to see you all of the place
thanks for coming on that's Rob Corddry
same on Twitter at Rob Corddry with 2ds
to hours around the day's pick up oh so
heavy that magazine do you want that
comic oh no you do I do not you sure
I've already forgotten all about it what
are you talking about the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country
and audience isn't it amazing you can
download an app with your thumbprint you
should download our app with your
thumbprint